[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 175 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mok Mandal and I'm here today with
my colleague John Fowles
John how are you doing I'm doing great
that's good glad to hear it
I hope it's warmer in New York than it
is here in San Francisco I don't think
so it's like 50 it's like 50 degrees
right now okay that's not particularly
warm so this week we're talking to
Andrew Davidson from MongoDB talking all
about the platform and how people can
use it on top of Google cloud very
awesome got to meet him on the showcase
floor a little bit earlier so really
excited to talk to this guy but before
we talk to Andrew we have our usual
question of the week where you're gonna
ask me how can I access the Google cloud
shell from any terminal it's like a
magic yeah it sounds very interesting
but before we do that we have our usual
cool things of the week
[Applause]
John why don't you get first I know you
have a good one sure we are announcing
the indie games accelerator which is a
program that is accepting the top indie
developers and flying them out to our
Google Singapore office where they will
attend a program that helps them
manifest their actual game and you know
get ready for Google Play very nice very
nice as we both know we both love games
yeah exactly once you highlight a
project that we started and worked on by
one of our team members set Vargo it is
a project called Berglas I'm gonna
assume I'm pronouncing that correctly it
is an open-source project that is a
command line tool and library for
storing and retrieving secrets on Google
Cloud so basically if you just want a
really nice wrapped up tool for taking
things like passwords things that are
secret credentials things like that
encrypting them with kms storing them
retrieving them that kind of stuff
bread glasses for you you should check
it out we'll have a link in the show
notes moving on we are talking about the
American Cancer Association using google
cloud - you know empower their cancer
research the study accepts a little bit
more than 180 for men and women and
looks into their height weight
demographic characteristics personal
family history and they you know use
this data to actually help analyze
breast cancer tissue samples and other
things that they are trying to fight
because you know cancer is one of the
leading causes of death in America
Walsman work so our good friends in
video we've had a recent episode talking
about their T fours
back in February episode 168 but the
great news is is the T 4 is now
generally available so if you have
particular needs around high-performance
computing machine learning training
inference data analytics graphics etc
you can now take advantage of general
availability of the Nvidia t4 GPU and I
think it's generally available in
roughly around eight regions right now
that seems about right
and to wrap things up this is a really
cool story there's a 70 year old
scientists who's interning at NASA named
Lisa Goldberg who's actually using
Google Earth engine to analyze force
change at a global scale
so she's track
climate change which is really awesome
very very cool inspirational yes
excellent well why don't we go chat with
our buddy Andrew and he can tell us all
the things about MongoDB
[Music]
welcome we are joined today by Andrew
Davidson from MongoDB hey Andrew how's
it going doing real well thank you good
to be on the floor of the Google next
conference expo listen
awesome you want to tell us a little bit
about yourself sure yes I'm Andrew
Davidson I'm the director of cloud
products for MongoDB we're a company
with a global headquarters in New York
City but we're all over the world and
yep I live in New York been there about
six years now with MongoDB but I'm from
the Bay Area originally so I'm really
happy to be getting my fill of burritos
while I'm in town so that's a lengthy
title you have there director of cloud
services what does that mean yeah I mean
I I primarily focus on MongoDB Atlas
which is our database as a service from
a product perspective so ensuring that
what we're building is a great
experience for our customers giving them
a global databases of service on GC p4
MongoDB as up front in New York our
welcome
well actually what is MongoDB cuz like a
lot of us haven't actually touched
MongoDB in a while some of us so yeah
feel free to tell us what that is
sounds good yeah we talked to folks who
arranged the whole spectrum of I use my
own gonna be you know and years ago you
know my experience of that was probably
something that was you know this thing I
could download and I found online around
some tutorial like back in 2000 you know
14 to folks who are really kind accurate
actually but yeah I'm not gonna be today
who know what kind of inside and out yep
and then there's folks who haven't used
it all and they've just been using
relational databases table based
database their whole life so MongoDB is
a document database and basically the
reason why it took off the reason why
it's just been so popular really the
core reason is it just stores natively
the json data model which is what
developers love i think they're objects
right in their code and they get to
write them directly to the database they
don't need that object relational
mapping ymore they don't have that
impedance mismatch and then with that
json data which is this new standard
across the board with MongoDB they can
index into any of the fields into any of
the arrays sub documents so they don't
keep up any of the rich query ability
that they need to build modern
applications no is that what you find
generally speaking why you see customers
coming to like no sequel in general like
is it that additive flexibility is that
is that kind of what's going on there
that's a great question you know we
don't tend to use the term no sequel
I'll tell you why
in my view no sequel it's kind of a lot
of people when they hear that I think
they think of a specific kind of
database called key value okay I'm key
value is kind of a subset of what
MongoDB can do because I said a simple
naive document where you just you know
index on one field and lookup on it
that's essentially key value but the
ability to also be able to index on any
compound set of fields etc makes it a
much more rich structure so document
kind of becomes the super set of key
value and something more like our
traditional table based databases the
reason that's important is what drove
the adoption of these no sequel
databases over the last 10 years
although you don't use that time oh you
mean broadly broadly yeah what drove the
adoption was basically scalability and
availability requirements forcing us to
break away from traditional monolithic
table based databases so a lot of us
kind of mentally when we hear no secret
we jump into the idea of super scalable
key value stores but all of a sudden
with key value stores you give up all
the query ability so you end up doing a
ton of ETL into relational systems just
to kind of maintain your reporting et
cetera MongoDB is this perfect sweet
spot you've got that JSON data model we
talked about you've got the scalability
that comes from a distributed system
comes from horizontal scale out with
y'all gonna be sharding you've got the
high availability that comes from the
distributed system replication built-in
fault tolerance auto failover you've got
the ability to move the data and have it
be you know where it needs to be closest
to users so you've got data locality
latency concerns all of that you can
only do the distributed systems you need
a modern database for that yep and then
you've got the ubiquity of being able to
run it anywhere ranging from the
developer laptop to corporate datacenter
to Google Cloud I'm not gonna be Atlas
yep as a service so I think we're
uniquely positioned in the market to
have all those things and that's what's
just driving modern application
developers for general purpose workloads
so you just mention Atlas and I know
that we have just announced our
partnership with MongoDB you'd care to
talk a little bit more about Atlas for
our listeners sure
so am I'm gonna be Atlas is a global
database as a service for MongoDB as
elastic meaning you can scale at any
time vertically horizontally with no
downtime it's very much a declarative
model so what we've kind of seen is this
proliferation of application developers
are moving to a model where they're
breaking everything up into micro
services and each micro service in
paradigm will typically have its own
database behind it and what that means
is there's kind of a proliferation of
large numbers of databases more than
ever before you don't just kind of have
that one large monolith database
someone's maintaining in the middle
anymore instead there's you know dozens
of them around the shop doing all kinds
of little services to massive backends
for the core of the application what
that means is you need to be able to
abstract away all of the overhead
concern frankly plumbing that goes into
managing not just databases but
everything underneath them the
infrastructure the cloud instances the
operating system the networking security
configurations and all the rest and
instead have it be encapsulated in just
declarative API call ready descriptive I
get a cluster now when I want it it's
not my fingers and I'm an app dev and I
get my database that's the model for
Atlas and it's just exactly what folks
expect today but a lot of my own gonna
be users don't actually know among the
Atlas exists and they're kind of still
doing the traditional model of i
download manga to be the PM software i
installed on my google cloud instance
and then i have to manage that so one of
the main reasons I'm excited about this
announcement is what get the awareness
out you know yeah all of our manga to be
community of users out there for them to
not know that Atlas exists and that they
can easily live migrated into it and
suddenly get all the benefits of being
in the modern world of true as a service
at the data tier it's a game changer for
them actually you said something really
interesting they're just real quickly
you said that you can migrate if they're
like easy migration paths because I've
done that right like I'm like I've spent
up there like three or four VMs I'm
running like replication across them or
whoever I want to set it up and then if
I want to go from that to Atlas is that
an easy journey
great question yeah so it's a very easy
journey so you'd spin up an atlas
cluster you then click into our live
migration and basically from there you
can connect to a MongoDB cluster that's
running in your own self-managed
environment of GCP or you can connect to
your environment on the data center on
Prem and basically we're gonna pull the
data over do the initial sync and we're
gonna apply all the changes that have
happened since the start of it get you
caught up in terms of the operation time
once you're caught up you can literally
just down to your app servers pointing
out the new connection string and you're
over does that mean then you can do
hybrid cloud too so MongoDB is very much
built for that world you know you can
run it in any context I wouldn't say
that an Atlas cluster can sort of span
both Google Cloud for example and on
Prem exactly but it's more like you can
have clusters in both Khan
and use manga to be the same way in both
places that makes sense consistently
that makes the same API for the
developer essentially no matter where
you're running it okay so I happen to
stop by the MongoDB booth and I got to
talk with a very very friendly ropes
over there and one of the things that
came out of our conversation was the
mention of global VP C's so I was
wondering if you could tell listeners a
little bit more although I found out
about at the booth to be completely
honest we love Google cloud platform
we're big fans of it we've been close
partners for really the last three years
you know Atlas launched three years ago
and this announcement that came out this
week about our much deeper partnership
is just a continuation of that and one
of the reasons we've always loved Google
cloud is the nature of the global VPC
which frankly the other cloud platforms
just don't have can you explain what
that is for people who don't agree it
means that you can inside of a virtual
private cloud and inside of a virtual
network as a Google cloud user you can
easily build your networking across any
set of regions around the world you
don't have to set up frankly a VPC per
region and figure out how to connect
them all to each other which is like an
end-to-end many challenge instead it's
just one big network environment
globally and the reason why we find that
really compelling and symbiotic with
MongoDB Atlas is that we specialize in
doing something called global clusters a
global cluster is a cluster that
essentially has different zones around
the world that can take rice inside of
the same cluster so I might have my US
portion of my global cluster in my
European portion of my Southeast Asia
portion and customers in the US for
example in Canada nearby their data will
automatically read and write to the US
portion of the cluster European data
will read and write to the Frankfurt
portion let's say and the same Southeast
Asia customers will read and write to
Singapore so the data doesn't have to
leave the region and it gives you in
regional agencies now that's super
powerful it's something that we have in
Atlas it's easy to configure that and
actually literally the way you use it is
you define in your document in your
schema you put a little location field
that describes the country of where the
client is and that's where the document
goes and cloche simple as that
that's fine and good but the question is
can our customer actually use this can
they connect to it easily and build
their app tier on top of that database
yep on Google it's so easy because all
they have to have is one global vbc on
their app tier as well they can set up
their app instances all over the world
and have them connect to that Atlas
cluster which is simply one VPC peer in
connection into GCP and we're good to go
that's
amazing that global cluster is that
specific to Atlas or is that okay so you
could do that yourself with MongoDB I
mean this is ultimately we're using
capabilities that the core database
engine has yep but it's just the epitome
of just easy yeah if you do it yourself
there's so much setup and it's just all
that stuff that nobody wants to be doing
anymore because it's far removed from
what matters to their business their
customers yeah
but being able to build in region
latency experiences for global audience
we see that as a very compelling thing
for more and more customers who for a
long time have gotten away with
providing you know excellent experience
for us customers and maybe not it okay
for Europe and then sort of rest of
world we'll figure it out later
increasingly it's like no these are huge
economies growing fast we can't afford
to deprioritize them let's give them a
great experience we've got amazing
adoption on Atlas and you know countries
like India I think some of the largest
fantasy cricket cricket leagues in the
world for example running on Atlas and
it's just a real testament to how folks
can come in on their own sign up get
going and reach any level of scale so
quickly know that's super cool
we sort of alluded to it a couple of
times but we're talking about that
deeper partnership with Google cloud can
you tell us a little bit about that
especially for people who weren't here
at nextdoor didn't see the live streams
yeah so what was announced by Thomas
Kurian in the keynote on Tuesday morning
of this week was Google recognizes the
strategic importance of openness and of
harnessing the open source community of
which Mugabe is a key part at this point
and so it's part of that Google has
worked very closely with us and we're
gonna continue working very closely to
build out a first-class experience for
MongoDB Atlas native to the Google Cloud
console right so this is the kind of
thing where it's ongoing work to keep
making it a better and better experience
initially it'll be more of a marketplace
integration but eventually it's gonna be
the kind of thing we're inside of Google
Cloud console you can essentially
describe the Atlas cluster you want to
deploy it right so it's all about making
it easier than ever it's all about
aligning our go-to-market operations so
that our customers don't have to sort of
feel like who should I be talking to all
the incentives are lined up
appropriately and I think it's just a
testament that Google realizes it should
open up to the community and that that's
gonna be a win for its customers
kubernetes has been a game changer for
Google because it has enabled Google to
level the playing field between the
cloud providers make it easier to move
around and our whole philosophy with
MongoDB is that it should be super easy
to run your database anywhere
consistently as well so it's
a lot of synergies with the whole
strategy Google's got and we think it'll
just make it easier for everyone to
migrate into Google cloud on Atlas no it
sounds amazing I guess that means then
right like it doesn't matter whether a
customer like comes to you and they're
like we want to run this a Google cloud
or they come to us and they're like
we're looking for a MongoDB solution
exact people end up pretty much in the
same place it's a win-win for both
parties Marc I don't know if you happen
to stop by the MongoDB booth but I have
not had the chance now I actually got to
see Atlas in action and one of the
things that really struck me as really
amazing was your analytics and your
metrics sure and monitoring your
clusters anywhere so can you speak a
little bit more about that for our
listeners who will not be able to see
that depending whether or not they use
the instance or not so yeah so I'll tell
you know everyone on the line you it's
really as simple as Google I'm gonna be
Atlas sign up you can do a free forever
free tier sandbox anytime you can deploy
your cluster and be up and running in a
couple minutes time super easy we've got
all kinds of courseware and tutorials to
learn how to build an app on it if
you're interested you know we've got all
the bells and whistles you need for
production database ranging from you
know real-time monitoring to historic
metrics to index suggestions based on
slow queries we've got a data Explorer
so you can go in there and really look
at your schemas you know update your
documents do anything you need run
queries but absolutely you know MongoDB
our sweet spot has always been
operational database
you know OLTP that the backend of online
applications engagement applications
strategic applications where customers
are interfacing but increasingly folks
have needs of course to be able to
report on and understand what's going on
in those environments and so we've got
the ability to spin up again going back
to our distributed system you can spin
up an analytics replica calling the
analytics node and you can actually with
true workload isolation do deep
aggregations leveraging all those same
indexes and do any kinds of reporting
you want on top of your online cluster
and truly have it isolated the same
connection string super easy to set up
and that allows you to not necessarily
need to do those burdensome ETL jobs to
your you know traditional wherever
you're going with it but also we've got
something called manga to be charts
which basically gives you native
business intelligence visualization
donuts on top of the manga to be data
model you know none of the other popular
BI solutions out there really excel at
the JSON data model they always kind of
have you force that into the tables
idea and you lose the fidelity whereas
what we've built with MongoDB charts is
we don't to give up that Fidel
instead you can unwind arrays and deal
with sub documents in a totally manga to
be native manner and build all those
beautiful visualizations you do you have
some sort of DSL for writing those
queries to pull stuff into charts like
how do I build charts on that yeah so if
you deploy manga to be Atlas you just
click into charts on the left side and
it's just a native part of cloud
platform yeah but in fact if I'm like oh
I want a pie chart with like this data
is there a particular tool that I use
literally we've got a beautiful GUI
right yeah just point and click and do
stuff nice very nice
also what seemed very interesting was
the ability to shard your clusters the
demo for that was pretty amazing
especially when you have to deal with
you know fall overs and everything like
that so teach me a little bit about that
yeah sure so let's talk a little bit
more specifically about how the
distributed system works among it
abilities is there's kind of couple
layers to talk about before we talk
sharding which is more about scalability
let's talk about replication which is
about high availability so among Adobe
atlas for example every cluster is
automatically minimum three node
replicas set on the back end that's
simply three replicas spread across
availability zones in your target Google
Cloud region or you can go across
multiple Google Cloud regions do want to
withstand full region outages that kind
of thing now the way that replication
works is essentially between those three
they elect a leader a primary we call it
where rights go and the other to follow
that if that one ever goes down then the
other two among themselves will elect a
new primary so this gives you that high
availability that you need with like a
two-second auto failover in the event
that there's an outage of that primary
right and this is a key building block
that allows us to also do the vertical
scalability seamlessly in other words if
you want to double your throughput
because Black Friday's coming up or your
game is super popular or whatever your
reason for scaling up that's a couple of
clicks in the Atlas UI or an API call
and what we'll do is actually scale you
up in such a way that will leverage that
distributed system we're gonna do
secondary then a secondary than a
primary causing one of those quick two
second elections we call them all
meaning that essentially you have a no
downtime way of scaling up and down at
any time so that's vertical scalability
which is really good for quick reactions
to demand is when you take vertical
scalability that's like increasing like
CPU and memory
yes--you and memory and storage etc yep
so that's really good for you know just
basically I would describe as I need to
quickly scale especially if I might want
to scale back down later now there's
another kind of scaling which is what
sharding is all about horizontal scale
out
it's not so much about like quick or
reactive scaling it's more for like
long-term linear scale out so let's say
I've got a million new users coming on
the platform every three months maybe I
need a new shard to be added every you
know three months as a result we can
simply do that in Atlas and you set up
your cluster every three months you add
a new shard and then basically you're
just distributing your cluster
horizontally what's gonna happen on the
back end is subsets of the documents
that are in collections which is kind of
like [ __ ] to bees named for what you
traditionally might have called the
table those documents in those
collections will be spread across the
available shards and there's various
strategies for how one selects their
shard key depending on what you want
optimized for etc but essentially this
means that you can go up to any level of
scale and that's why you know for those
of you who may have kids on the line or
for those of you who are yourselves
addicts if you're playing fortnight all
night the level of scale that powers the
back end of fortnight
that's mild good eBay and the reason
that's possible is again the sharding
the scale out capability you just can't
do that level of scale without charting
but for a lot of applications start
simple simple a single replica set yep
vertically scaled and then you can start
scaling out when you need to and
interesting maybe question on the
sharding aspect as well like I assume
there are controls in there for like
redundancy of data things like that
basically so you don't like you have
just like one copy of data on one
machine right so that's what the
replication is in other words yes I kind
of jumped over that every shard in Atlas
just automatically is a replica set
that's just a building block you don't
to worry about so you can have n shards
each of those shards is always gonna be
spread across those daisies availability
zones gzp or across the multiple regions
if you prefer right yeah I'm curious
what your favorite feature of MongoDB is
that's a great question so I mean I
talked already about just the
fundamentals of the JSON data model I
think a favorite new feature that I
would have to mention there's two one
was in ma gonna be three point six which
is again capabilities that folks who use
mugabe years ago just have no idea about
probably in three six we introduced
changed streams which lets you follow
what's happening changes in the database
and do all kinds of interesting triggers
based on that on top of [ __ ] to be
Atlas we've got a service layer called
MongoDB stitch and you can do things
like triggers and functions based on
changes in those change streams and
power all kinds of real-time
applications that way but then the other
one that I have to mention just because
we've been waiting on this for
time in manga to be 4.0 which came out
last year we introduced multi document
asset transactions in Naga DB which was
that touch a game changer this ya know
people think they need transactions they
oftentimes in MongoDB because we have
atomic transactions the document level
yeah The Times don't need them because
you're not spreading your data across
tables anymore so everything changes you
know you do normalize into a document
that describes a business entity that's
the MongoDB model but still being able
to when you need them have transactional
semantics to be able to change multiple
documents together that was a key
building block that went into hardening
MongoDB came out last year and now
that's a huge step forward thrust yes so
what's been also like the most
interesting or maybe weird thing that
you've seen people do with MongoDB that
you can talk about publicly I mean I
have to search my mind on now and only
because there's so much you know it's
absolutely incredible to have the scale
of customers we've got like Atlas alone
you've got about 10,000 customers four
hundred percent year-over-year growth
but I kid you not we have three hundred
thousand users of our free tier look at
the manga to be community at wild it's
hundreds of thousands of manga to be
users doing all kinds of stuff so it's
more like every day I'm exposed to
millions of different use cases for
manga to be and it's everything under
the Sun ranging from like I said before
powering your most popular game in the
world fortnight to fantasy cricket
leagues in India to you know a Tier one
banking application that powers your
mobile device that's running on your
mobile device some of the more
interesting use cases range from
basically think about the apps that you
know and love the most think about like
dating apps think about things that are
really about engaging your real life
making your your real life more more fun
and interactive with other people I
think some of those are work it's really
interesting some of the IOT applications
where folks have devices out in the real
world that do all kinds of interesting
things and bring it all home those are
also quite interesting so you mentioned
community I was wondering what kind of
support does MongoDB give for the
community sure I mean I'm gonna be his
just enormous community we've got these
community created [ __ ] to be user
groups which happen really in cities all
over the world I invite everyone to
check out their local [ __ ] to be user
group I'm sure you can find it on Meetup
and you know go in there and just
connect with local folks we've got
something called MongoDB University
which has over 1 million
literally over 1 million registrants if
you can believe it which is gonna
provide on-demand video style coursework
for folks to learn about my gonna be
whether they're Python developers know
developers Java or coming from a DBA
background all kinds of course is there
you know the incredible tutorials
documentation we focus a ton on all of
that stuff we recognize that we're in a
long-term secular shift a multi-decade
secular shift away from a world where we
think in terms of tables to a world in
which we think in terms of JSON style
documents and that we need to continue
to help everyone evolve how they think
and it doesn't happen overnight so we
really focus on so much of that we we do
a MongoDB Roadshow conference style
called manga to be dot local which run
in cities all over the world there's one
of those happening every few weeks and
then we have our big annual conference
MongoDB world in June in New York City
let's talk a little bit at that secular
shift that's happening because I think
it's controversial to kind of say we all
came up on table based databases and
we're gonna start seeing it shift I
think across the board towards JSON rich
structured data style databases it's
controversial because we're all
hardwired to expect table based
databases now I'm gonna argue that the
reason table based databases were
introduced and why they had become
ubiquitous is that if you look at their
origin back in the 1970s at that time
the key problem table database that was
solving was that storage was the key
cost bottleneck in computing you could
throw as many people at a problem as you
wanted but you needed to optimize for
storage so it's important to normalize
everything as much as possible to just
simply reduce storage footprint
flash-forward to 2019 I always ask
people that's like what do you think the
primary costs or just what is the
primary bottleneck of today I don't
answer wrong people have all kind of
different answers but I would argue the
key bottleneck today is our minds
particularly developers Minds okay so if
a developer can feel superpowers by
using a data model that has no impedance
mismatch database that has no competes
mismatch with the data model they
already use natively in their code they
can do a heck of a lot more faster and
when storage is frankly commoditize very
cheap yeah everything is switched so
it's not that this change happens
overnight there's just so much inertia I
mean databases are not things that
change fast
huge cost to refactor and there's no way
all these table based databases are just
gonna become long gonna be I mean that's
not gonna happen overnight you know
we're realists we recognize that
maintenance mode status quo applications
they're not gonna change even if they
move to the cloud they're not gonna be
materially changed what's happening is
folks are looking at their applications
and they're moving to modern database
like MongoDB for applications that are
on the cutting edge of what matters to
those businesses whether they're
upstarts trying to disrupt or they're
establish companies that have a
strategic business initiative that they
know they need to thrive on or else they
will be disrupted those are the apps
where they need to benefit from the
modern tools of agility that developers
can wield like MongoDB so it's sort of
this we're gonna we're gonna see it
adopted more and more but the cool thing
is it's being adopted in the most
exciting applications not in those
status quo ones so to answer your
question around you know someone who's
thinking about making the shift from
table based database system I'm gonna be
my suggestion is it sounds scary but all
you need to do is look at your code so
if you're a Java developer or Python
developer whatever it is look at your
code look at your objects imagine if you
didn't have to have an object relational
map and you could simply take that
object write it directly into the
database index on any field in that
database so you can query however you
want later when you read it back from
the database it's simply your object
again using Mugabe's built-in drivers
for all the programming languages it's
really as simple as that it's all of a
sudden it's not that scary it's like
there's actually not much there you're
just going directly to the database
instead of going through that mapping
layer that introduces this traditional
pain now folks are scared of this too
because there's so much that has gone
into integrity and schemas and people
really for good reason have built mature
applications over time with a lot of
controls in there and making it scared
of adopting long to be like send me a
wild west of schemas and that's where I
would say you know we have something
called JSON schema so you can control
your schemas among independents if you
want to but with the full richness
flexibility and expressiveness of JSON
again it's just all the benefits of what
we our modern tool chain looks like
fantastic yeah I'm not gonna lie your
speech on bottlenecks and databases
makes me believe that pretty soon there
will be something called Davidson's law
so what can people expect for among gray
to be in the near future like is there
any cool and updated new features coming
soon there are always cool and new
features coming soon with MongoDB
generally I don't like to share what's
coming in this forum because we're not
going investment I'll be honest we're a
public company now you know we've got
these incredible public numbers that
ever in the world sees and as a result
there's things I can't share but I can
tell you that you should always stay
tuned particularly traditionally we've
been out made our biggest announcement
at MongoDB world which is happening this
June in New York City and is there any
way we can follow online say a
newsletter or something we can sign up
for it to find anymore news absolutely
you can follow us on hashtag MongoDB of
course on Twitter you can really sign up
on any of our websites but my main
suggestion for you is just sign up for
mom gonna be Atlas today particularly if
you're developer out there and you just
want to give it a go five minutes to get
started and have a hello world
experience with mom gonna be in the
cloud free forever free tier on GCP we
have free regions all over the world for
you to try all the tutorials need to get
started and have that aha moment with
MongoDB so you get what's going on and I
think you'll immediately see how you can
use it to solve problems that matter to
you
fantastic well thank you so much for
joining us here at next in the podcast
house thanks so much for having me great
to meet you guys nice to meet you so
thank you to Andrew Davidson from
MongoDB it was a great and very
interesting chat and a lot of fun and
moving on we're going to go into our
question of the week
how can I access google cloud shelf from
any terminal mark that is a very good
question John so if those people who
aren't familiar with Google cloud shell
this is a really cool little thing that
if you go into the Google console
there's a little icon that looks like a
terminal click that and inside your
browser it will pop up a terminal that
has like basically all the standard
tooling that you need for doing just
about anything so AG cloud get-go Python
etc etc it's super handy it persists
your home directory ever like resets and
like if you come back to it after a
while bring all the stuff back again you
know for a period of time really really
handy stuff but you might find there are
scenarios where you're like wow I really
wish I could access my cloud show from
the terminal just on my local machine
there's a bunch of different tools that
are available now they're an alpha but
you will have links to them in the show
notes
if you run g-cloud alpha cloud shell ssh
it will ssh into your cloud shell
terminal and make it available locally
basically through SSH which is super
super nice you can also use the G cloud
alpha cloud shell commands to SCP files
up and down so if you want to bring
local files to the machine or bring them
down as well but the thing that gets me
actually really excited is that the G
cloud alpha cloud shell command has a
get mount command so if you're running a
Linux or Mac OS and basically anything
they can support sshfs it will give you
the command to mount your cloud shell
locally using SSH FS I think this is
super cool because maybe if you're
running on a machine maybe it doesn't
have as much power or maybe as much
network bandwidth as you would have
running on GCP itself in the cloud show
environment what you could do is mount
your directory locally use your local
tools to edit those files and then run
your commands to say doc or build
something or pull down things off the
internet that may be a really large do
that in the cloud shell environment and
then have access to that but still have
your local tooling as well I think
that's super cool I'm very excited about
it someone give it a shot
yeah it sounds pretty cool and I can
tell from the excitement of your voice
that you're about to start playing with
it right after this probably awesome all
right well jump before we wrap up today
where are you going you doing anything
fun in the near future well I will be
attending my first Google i/o next week
so that's gonna be pretty awesome it is
gonna be pretty awesome and I will see
you there I will be there as well giving
a talk and I think we're both stuffing
office hours and probably some demo
stuff too
yeah so if you're around be sure to come
stop by and say hey we heard your voice
yep we'll probably be able to find us
over in the games area right all right
whoa John thank you so much for joining
me this week on the podcast thank you
you know it's always a pleasure and
thank you all for listening and we'll
see you all next week
see it
[Music]